for some perspective on all this we turn
to CBS News political director Steve
shigera Steve good morning morning how
did this tax deal get done well you
heard Errol talking about it they're
waiting for some Republicans who are
holding out on child tax credit bob
Corker was concerned about the deficits
that this will create but everybody's on
board it's pretty amazing to hear all
Republicans in the Senate are backing
this thing which is something we haven't
seen with legislation on Capitol Hill at
all this year Steve what are the
political implications of this bill for
Republicans in 2018 given the speed with
which this has been passed it's going to
probably be passed through Congress so
there's two things one Republicans have
been talking about since they were
unable to get Obamacare repeal or in
place through that there was a impetus
to get something done they have to show
voters that they can accomplish
something you remember Paul Ryan earlier
in the year on the house side said we
have to learn how to govern as a
Republican party not just be opposition
so this is an opportunity for them to
say we can't actually do something and
here's something tangible however how is
this going to affect the campaign's next
year in the midterm we don't know the
answer that question because voters
really won't have a sense because these
tax cuts won't take won't take part
until next year right you won't really
feel it until you you file your taxes in
April of 2019 so after the midterms so
well Democrats certainly have talking
points for what they'll have talking
points but there's standard Democratic
talking points right this is for the
wealthy and for corporations and but
that's what they're gonna say anyway
about Republicans it's like does this
but do will voters feel the impact of
this immediately probably not they
probably won't feel it until after the
midterms at the same time though the
earlier indications are the polls
suggest that this is not a popular bill
that's right and and you know it much in
it is this could this come back to haunt
Republicans the way Obamacare did the
Democrat it could but if Republicans and
what they're banking on is hoping that
there's a boost in the economy because
of this right they're hoping that you
bring these corporate tax rates down
that will continue to help the stock
market maybe boost the economy and then
they can point to that in November and
say hey look you got us in here to fix
the economy we have fixed the economy so
they hope they can run on that next year
understanding that the majority of these
tax cuts don't take effect until 2019
that's right it's gonna be it's gonna be
it's gonna be a long right but Wall
Street's gonna be very excited when this
bill gets passed correct and so they'll
see the stock market going up and again
perhaps that image of uh they could at
least argue the economy is improving
maybe that helps their cause what about
Doug Jones and Roy Moore here see the
fight is not yet over if you talk
anymore it's over for most people I mean
you had the president come out this week
and say it's time to end this thing Roy
Moore is hanging on I think he's he's
hoping that whatever uncounted ballots
will change the count here but the way
that law is in Alabama is if if the
margin of error is 0.5% or less it would
trigger an automatic recount it's not
going to get to that point where more
Moore is hoping is perhaps he could
start his own recount however the laws
are fairly clear in Alabama that you
can't do that in a Senate race however
some people say you might be able to do
it it would cost him a lot of money to
do it he doesn't have any money left so
I don't know who would pay for a recount
even if you could do it what's the
feeling in Washington about this race is
this is is was Roy Moore an outlier or
was the fact that the the President and
Steve Bannon could not deliver this seat
a safe Republican seat is that an
indication of where things may stand
next year at the midterms well that's a
really good question and so Republicans
I've been saying from the get-go on this
that there's no good outcome for
Republicans on this they lose a seat in
the Senate when when Jones is sworn in
it's down to a 51/49 majority which is
not good for their prospects in terms of
passing legislation but in terms of
politics at least the silver lining in
this you're hearing from Republicans is
this really hurts Steve Bannon Steve
Bannon went full behind Roy Moore was
unable to get him a victory in fact lost
a seat in a very Republican State
because of the quality of candidate in
Roy Moore yes he's an outlier and
outlier in some sense but you saw the
president go out there and try to
campaign for him wasn't able to push him
ahead Democrats seem to think this is
going to be a prediction of what's gonna
happen next year the midterms because
it's a referendum on president Trump but
Roy Moore had a lot of problems it
wasn't just president Trump and Steve
and Roy Morehead he was a flood cam well
you one would assume though that the
Senate race is that the Democrats are
going to be fighting for in 2018 we're
gonna hear the name Roy Moore he will
effectively be used as a litmus test yes
but the nice thing for Republicans is
that Roy Moore won't be in office he'll
be he'll be that'll be in the rearview
mirror
for a while about November next year
it's going to be an interesting next
year absolutely
no wait Steve shigera thanks as always